hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
al quinn of york in his treatise on
virtues and vices is going to make use
of by that time a
traditional schema of the eight capital
vices which comes from earlier monastic
authors centuries before of agrius
ponticus and then most notably john
cassian these are going to get turned
into the seven deadly sins so if you're
thinking when you hear these about the
seven deadly sins that well that's
coming from gregory the great who takes
the eight capital vices and changes up
the list a little bit but the first
three are going to remain
rather constant so here we're going to
talk about gluttony gula
lost in alkaline's case for nicazio
sometimes also libido or other latin
terms and then greed or avarice
avaritsya and he devotes three chapters
to these uh chapters 28 29 and 30. he is
also going to be discussing greed as
well in
chapter 19 which is about avoiding fraud
and you say well how does that connect
with greed well you you engage in fraud
because of greed and he says some
interesting things about it there so
let's start out with gluttony he says
gluttony is the first of the corporeal
or corporal
sins or vices and he uses the word sin
their picatum right and he uh tells us
that
through this the first parents of the
human race lost the happiness or
felicity of paradise and were ejected
into the wretched misery of this life
where we are born through sin live
through work and die through sorrow so
it's interesting here that there's a
little bit of you know discussion of
typically we think of the first sin as
being one of disobedience but it's also
in this case for alkaline gluttony
and what is gluttony well he tells us
it's intemperate desire
one way to translate it voluptas for
food and drink and i want to linger on
this word volaptos for a moment it's not
just desire
it's taking pleasure
within these things in in one mode or
another so why do you have that desire
because eating you know tasty stuff is
kind of fun right drinking could be
about the act of actually drinking
things or it could be about the
intoxication
food and drink do things to our bodies
that we like and so he tells us
this seems to live in people in three
ways now that seems is saying i'm not
saying that this is the only possible
ways in which we can have the you know
this this
sin or vice arising but these are three
main ways
and the first one is very interesting
he says when a person desires to
anticipate the canonical and statuary
hours for the sake of greed what does
this mean well remember alcoin is a monk
so within the monastery you don't just
like
go over and open up the fridge and look
inside you know around midnight and say
hmm
i've got a taste for something i don't
know what it is no no no they don't have
refrigerators to begin with but you get
the idea you don't go to the kitchen or
the larder and start poking around
you are supposed to eat and drink at
specified times so you know having a
kind of routine for eating that's one
way in which gluttony might express
itself another that he says which is
really really interesting
has to do with expensive foods
orders more expensive foods prepared for
himself and now notice there's two
characteristics here
then the needs of the body
or the quality of his person
demands so in a certain sense if you're
like well i only eat the best foods i
don't eat a lot of things but i i eat
really really good food you know is that
what's required for the health of your
body i suppose if you're not being
precious
about it or being kind of silly about it
or elitist about it no you can actually
eat very cheaply uh quite well
if you you know learn how to cook and
how to shop and stuff like that so the
people who
you know require better food
or more expensive food than they they
actually need for health or as he says
their station demands why is he saying
that well this is the middle ages right
so he's writing to a guy who's a noble
right
and uh amounts now this is what we're
usually thinking about in terms of
gluttony um
eating more than you
actually need to taking more and eating
and drinking because of desires of
intemperance than may profit his health
so you know how notice health is being
discussed again
and so you know these are our problems
this is a
issue that's going to lead to other
issues let's move on to lust fornication
now
you know it can also be translated
directly as fornication and what does
that mean usually in the middle ages it
means screwing anybody who isn't your
spouse or engaging in sexual acts you
know that that aren't oriented
towards your spouse but he expands it he
doesn't just include sexuality there
he says that it is all uncleanness
in munditzia
of body
right
and where does this come from
comes from incontinence of desire
libidoness meaning giving into
desire when you know that you're not
supposed to be and this now this could
be lost right uh
libido right but also
weakness malicia softness is another way
of describing it of the soul so
it could pertain to more than just
having sex it could also pertain to you
know taking it too easy basking in the
sun all day remaining uh sleeping in
your bed until noon you know there's
this wonderful verse in in proverbs that
talks about the sluggard rolls on his
bed like a door on its hinges i mean we
might associate that with sloth instead
but you know this could actually part be
part of
lust and he says
that
you know the soul should be in charge
and command the flesh
and the flesh should be the servant and
obey her mistress that is the rational
soul how does this happen
now he uses sort of gendered sexual
language here because he's writing to a
guy who's a guy uh count guy right and
he says that it can happen
um through the mingling of flesh with
whatever woman right any woman
whatsoever right so uh that's what he
has in mind for for guy but really it
could be the mingling of flesh with
anybody right or again
any other uncleanness in satisfying the
ardor of desire what it is that our
bodies want that isn't directly
concerned with say food and drink but
other things that feel
good to us
then we have the third greed or avarice
and here we're moving out of bodily
primarily bodily uh vices into one
that's much more
spiritual one that's centered in in the
person's soul
avarice is another word for greed right
and it's an excessive desire and notice
that he says three things here
excessive desire of acquiring
excessive desire
of having
or excessive desire of
keeping riches so it's not just the
desire to acquire
it's also the desire to to have and to
retain to keep to keep our hands on
riches and these could be property these
could be money these could be
beautiful clothing these could be houses
these could be vehicles these could be
all sorts of other things as well
and it tells us that now this is very
interesting it's a
deadly filling up like the dropsicle man
who the more he drinks the more added
thirst increases for him so dropsy was a
common disease
or at least a symptom of disease that
would lead people to keep on they would
be thirsty and they would keep on
drinking water more water than was good
for them and eventually you know we know
that you'll
urinate all your electrolytes out and
it's not good for you and eventually you
have all sorts of health problems but
you don't realize it while it's
happening well the same thing happens
with the greedy person except it's not
about water
it's about
wealth wealth and its measures it could
just be about totally fictional things
like numbers in bank accounts that are
you know electronic transactions that
only exist you know think about all the
imaginary wealth that was lost in uh you
know when the valuations of things
declined in economic crises right
uh after you know big what we call
bubbles
so he says
the the more that a person has
the more they desire more
and since there's no moderation in this
having greed cannot moderate itself
there will be no moderation in
desiring and you know again he talks
about this a bit in that section about
avoiding fraud
he says that you know people get mixed
up right
um
say avariciously say greedily say
wickedly what have you acquired perhaps
you say i have acquired gold and you say
the truth
um but you know
is gold really going to benefit you you
know
and and so there's kind of a mistaken
view
a prioritization you could say about
what's genuinely valuable in that
section on avoiding fraud he says
why do you not fear to lose those things
that god wanted you to have in your
heart you have gold or silver and
another thing precious in its place but
damage in your heart with these things
you've lost the better
riches so the person who's suffering
from greed is actually going to make
other people suffer too this is
something we should talk about
but they they can't they can't see the
damage that they're actually doing to
themselves and that they can't make
themselves
happy he tells us that it's the opposite
of mercy and almsgiving it's the
opposite of generosity it's the opposite
of doing the right things with the
wealth that we have and that's why it's
such a
capital
vice
now he also is going to tell us that
each of these
vices
leads to a whole host
of other things a whole host of other
vices and sins let's work our way
backwards from greed what does greed
lead to he calls this the offspring of
it
envies
if you're greedy
you're going to be envious of other
people right
theft
highway robberies
homicide
lies perjury pillaging violence
restlessness
unjust judgments contempt of truth
forgiveness forgetfulness of future
blessedness hardness of heart what a
wide range of things
being greedy is going to lead to playing
fast and loose with the rules that
should govern any civilized society and
any relations with other people it can
lead to murder people kill each other
over money they rob each other they lie
about all sorts of things perjury lying
in a court of law
violence
unjust judgments it can lead to
cognitive deficits right contempt of
truth if it stands in the way of me
making money well then i'm not going to
believe in it
uh forgetfulness of future blessedness
think not thinking about you know the
life to come hardness of
heart
you know the kind of person who in the
in 1980s it was proverbial would walk
past a homeless person and say get a job
i mean people still do that today and
you know they they don't think about how
they should help those who are
misfortunate why because they're greedy
they desire to
keep what they have they desire to have
more wealth they won't open up their
wallet so to speak
let's work our way backwards what about
lust what does this lead to
so he tells us
what is what is coming from that
blindness of the mind
you know well think about the kind of
blindness that's involved in hookup
culture and jumping into bed with people
you know and then waking up and being
like oh this is a big mistake right uh
sometimes we used to joke about beer
goggles that people would put on uh or
you know
jumping into bed with somebody at the
end of our time
in constancy of the eyes not being able
to uh be in charge of what you're going
to look at immoderate love
of the whole body again not just sexual
it could be about well i need to have a
massage every single day or i'm not okay
right
um
peril of life well you know if you screw
around you can sometimes run into people
who are mad about that lewdness
jokes petulance and all incontinence
hatred of the mandates of god weakness
of mind and unjust desires negligence of
the future life delight of the
present so a lot of things that can come
out of lust as well
what about gluttony
are there problems that come out of
gluttony besides health issues
well he says
from this is born
unsuitable merriment which is you know
being uh joking in the wrong ways
scorility levity empty talk
uncleanliness of the body
instability of mind
drunkenness
desire
sense from fullness of the belly desire
of the body is prepared which is best
conquered through fastings and absence
this goes to an old idea which is that
you need to control
gluttony because when you're feeling you
know good and this may be sort of a
function of like
people not having enough food or
you know other factors like that it's
felt that when you're satisfied
physically then you can start to
lapse into all sorts of other
vices as well that in the you know when
you're more concerned about what how am
i going to eat that isn't quite such an
issue now each of these is also
opposed by a virtue but we we can talk
about that
elsewhere so you notice that these
capital vices gluttony lust and greed
are indeed capital vices they lead to a
lot of other problems alcoin is
providing the reader with some some
brief discussions of each of them
allowing them to be identified and to
understand
how and why they're problematic
you